ah vous êtes là nous sommes au tetris et
au havre pour vous parler de la
résidence d'un groupe cannes et samba de
la muerte ils viennent de sortir un
magnifique album
on est sympa de l'avoir t on est dans là
où ça bouge
le fan
peut-être qu'on va jouer cet été en
région mais on sait déjà qu'on va être
là à la rentrée
du côté de caen mais on va pas dire
il
voilà
la hauteur
travailler le son surtout toutes les
sources les morceaux avec monstres en
gestion et puis après dans la grande
salle on a travaillé la lumière la
création de lumière et toute la
scénographie
c'est en fait je cours je compose mes
morceaux c'est je fais d'abord les
instrumentaux et après j'essaye de
trouver des lignes de chant et là en
fait les lignes de chant qui venait
souvent c'était pas du yaourt en anglais
c'était des mots français sur 3 des
morceaux de l'album
les images
ouah
un sentiment qui cache le départ
bah
genève jamais ne sais pas
j'ai hâte de devoir d'avoir des retours
là dessus parce que c'est un exercice
assez difficile quand on est français
qu'on a chanté en anglais avant et une
course chante en français
les gens y sont c'est la langue
française
samba de la muerte sera en concert le 2
juin à la luciole d'alençon
la juge avait pour terminer deux
expositions à vous signaler tout d'abord
à granville avec le 67e salon des
artistes granville et est à peu près à
la même période jusqu'à fin avril
ici même à la mairie de caen le 89e
salon des artistes bas normands nous
avons un comité de sélection avec une
dizaine de membres du jury donc des
membres internes mais donc quatre
membres externes ce qui permet d'avoir
une grande ouverture à la fois dans les
approches et les tendances artistiques
mais également d'avoir l'assurance que
nous faisons les meilleurs choix
possibles en termes de qualité
artistique et sachant qu'on demande aux
artistes de venir
on passe le samedi entier et ont demandé
aux artistes de venir et ont choisi des
oeuvres qui sont exposées en les voyant
mais pas uniquement simplement par
internet et puis un petit clin d'oeil
pour terminer aux chanteurs amateurs de
l'atelier d'un tamar avec bête de scène
un spectacle qui reproduit tout
simplement le travail de l'année
c'est au foyer rural de cani demain soir
bon week-end